thank you for attending my talk this
morning today my name is Jerry bhutta
corn chip that's weird after the corn
tip in case you guys are interested in
hand it's a really long last name today
I want them to be talking about is tools
for quality control management I'm going
to talk about software tools that are
available especially one of our software
which we r which we called easy QC
online the website is w es q SI mi calm
going into this first of all our legal
and limitation statement that our legal
department asses us always to put on
this software it was this we're going to
be talking about our software we want to
ensure that the laboratory is still
responsible to meeting their local state
and national regulations to meet their
accreditation accreditation requirements
and so we're going to go into a little
bit about quality control management's
going to talk a little bit about this
and in quality control management it
could be pretty confusing and quite
daunting to a clinical laboratory
there's many stages to quality control
management what we see is here is a
quick break down there might there could
be more and there could be less but
basically what we see is that there's
validation there's training there's
maintenance and there's monitoring when
you validate it or verify your assay
this is going into the stages of
implementation of the assay where you're
looking at establishing linearity
accuracy dynamic range LOD loq precision
interfering substances reference ranges
there's a lot of experiments of law
statistics that need to be done in this
portion and then what are the guidelines
that need to be followed to validate and
to verify moving forward training making
sure that the operators are proficient
and running these assays are they
running them are they performing them
accurately are they performing them with
high level precision now the training
maintaining the performance of this
assay are we performing calibration
verification
are these operators proficient and even
are these labs proficient and finally
the last thing is monitoring are we
monitoring the performance of the asset
over time are we trending analysis even
further can we look at the performance
of this assay in comparison to other
peers so talking a little bit about the
challenges the as molecular testing gets
much more adopted there's a lot of how
to implement these assays what are the
guidelines and there are capped
checklists there's iso 1 5 189 there's
publications by new york state of New
York State what are these guidelines how
do you interpret these guidelines they
tell you what to run like they tell you
you need to want accuracy you need a run
precision but really what are the number
of days whether the number of runs one
of the number of replicates right now
what we've seen is that there's quite a
number of literature out there that talk
about how to perform these announcing
implementations these validations these
of verifications and we cite a lot of
these papers in this talk later on we
can talk about how they approach
validating their molecular assays just a
reminder if there's a questions during
this talk please feel free to put it
into your Q&A console and just ask and
we'll talk about we'll go over these
questions at the end of the talk so a
little bit about this software that
we've created we created a software that
kind of goes through all these NASA
implementation and it kind of
streamlines this entire process when we
look at this software it breaks down in
three modules the validation
verification which was the asset
implementation fortune I talked about
the calibration verification which is
the monitoring portion the the make of
the maintenance portion and then QC
monitoring which is the monitoring to
daily QC portion and how does the
software do this
it takes a couple inputs from the
laboratory it takes actually information
the instruments information the
materials and the guidelines it takes
this information and with this with this
information you can then create these
studies that can validation verification
excusing monitoring studies the software
guides you through each one of these
processes and then creates a report and
all the statistical analysis are
automatic computed later on at the end
of this talk I'm going to go a little
bit into the software how it works how
we designed it it's been a lot of work
was put into this offer a lot of
interviews with clinical lab directors
to kind of get their input because we
wanted to create a software that exactly
meets the clinical labs needs so let's
talk a little bit about validation
verification I'm going to go a little
bit over white labs easy to do
validation verification what are some of
the available guidelines that are out
there and go a little bit details and
then show a little bit software how it
helps as a validation verification so
validation verification well first of
all what is validation of what is
verification well verification is
defined by the FDA and ISIL guidelines
as confirmation so verification that the
performance characteristics are
established by the manufacturer the
manufacturer establishes the accuracy
the precision to Elodie any types of
interfering substances any types of
cross-reactivity and it's only the labs
of only responsibility is to verify
those performances engine and we'll go
into a little bit of guidance what does
verification exactly validation of your
hand is more intended for lab develop
tests or modified I ve tests and this is
where the lab now must establish the
performance characteristics okay and so
the next thing is well the cap checklist
requires that any verification be
performed for FDA cleared assays and
and even though I so 1 5 189 they go
into a little bit more detail about what
needs to be done during a validation or
a verification for example performance
requirements required are like ello DS
quantification limits linearity
sensitivity measurements but as you can
see this is a lot of words of statistics
but what exactly how do you perform
engineer a study how do you perform a
sensitivity study how do you set
acceptance and rejection criterias these
are the elements that these types of
guidelines don't go into details about
they don't tell us you need to run this
for four days you run six levels you
need to run three replicates of each
levels it doesn't go into details and so
this is where we actually have to look
for lit more literature that talks about
this and so one of the literature we
which we were going to reference is so
anybody dr. Ravenel and this is a paper
that he talked about pace you validating
a clinical biology test for iso 1 5 189
and he puts together a table showing
what's required when you're doing a
verification what's required during the
foundation as you can see from a
verification standpoint there's less
things that need to be done there's less
sensitivity there's no sensitivity
analysis there's no specificity
announced these are established by the
manufacturer but accuracy precision and
linearity is still required for this
laboratory to verify the pores of the
author and invalidation everything is
required another paper is by Lynn Sloan
from Mayo this paper was published in
2007 it was about validating pcr and
clinical microbiology there's a table in
this paper that's very very good it it
breaks down what's needs to be done in
an IV detest versus allow develop or a
modified test but it also breaks it down
between a difference between a
qualitative a safe and a quantitative
assay there's different levels and
different amounts of specimens required
and she goes into quite details about
what the cost
how many levels how many replicates
uneven how many days and so what we did
with this these papers is that we
programmed these recommendations into
the software so the software the
software stores these peer-reviewed
papers and then can be called upon to
look at these guidelines how many levels
how many replicas how many days so
summarizing the validation verification
fact background what needs to be done so
in a laboratory first of all again it's
guideline interpretation what did he do
to establish the molecular test they
typically refer we perfect typically
refer to other laboratories holiday
perform it and we also look at later so
we're interpreting the guidelines then
we must create our own protocols that
match up to these guidelines let's see
doing it meet these guidelines are we
passing to acceptance criteria then we
need to find the materials run the study
run the statistical analysis and review
and write a report and a lot of these
stages it can take a long time what
we've done is we dentist did a quick
study we were resurveyed quite a number
of people in 2010 and we found that an
average time to validate a molecular
tape test takes about 58 days 58
business days and some of it might be
shorter I mean we've talked to customers
where it's been under two weeks and
we've talked to people where it's taken
years a year and so with this case with
when we saw this when we talk to
customers we wanted to create a software
that kind of streamline this process
that could reduce some of the headaches
and reduce the time of the validation
verification and so we created this
offer which is what we call easy to see
and so we the workflow of the software
is basically designing your study where
you put in your information what asset
you're going to use what kind of
guidelines you want to follow what's
soft what what peer-reviewed paper do
you want to follow you can
modify these guidelines and I'm going to
show you a little bit more detail later
on how you do this you can then define
your study you can choose what materials
you want to use what's the acceptance
criteria define your personnel and then
the software automatically the protocol
and this protocol can then be taken into
the lab studies performed and
immediately the sovereign the results
can be uploaded into the software and
analyzed a report is generated and then
this report can be filed away with the
validation binder for this molecular
test so what does this offer to what
kind of experiments are the software
tackling well we're following things
that are recommended by the cap tekla is
an iso + 5 189 for example the cap
checklist it asks us to do accuracy and
precision study any limit of detection
studies also interfering substances and
quite a bit more and so in the software
it tackles all these statistics in
tackles precision in the precision it
tackles within run and between run we
tackle accuracy limit of detection by
probit analysis linearity dynamic range
we toggle interfering substances method
comparison so method correlation between
assays we also toggle clinical
sensitivity and specificity processor
activity reference ranges and control
limits which is in the QC monitoring
portion of the software so again this is
the homepage of the software easy QC
online com again it takes those four
stages design protocol performing
running the assay event looking at the
reports for simple stages in the
software when you first see when you log
into software is the home page and a
home page shows what our ongoing studies
what reports that you have available
what are the assets you have in in your
laboratory and what are the QC readings
and this dashboard allows you to quickly
link out to view all the pertinent
information and also shows you the stat
of your studies are you running it are
you completed is your controls within
the limits for QC monitoring so like I
mentioned in the software a bit before
we can actually want to study we must
set up the information in the laboratory
and so some of the absolute information
that's required is some of the
laboratory information that's required
is like asset information instrument
information than material set up some of
this is already predefined this is more
for lab developed test or and
identifying unique identifiers for the
instrument and when you set up an assay
you can name your assets identify the
number of targets so you can create a
multiplex assay with this with the
software what controls are required with
the software what reagents or what
controller and reagents are required
with the assay when you sell the
instrument you set up whether is
extraction information instrument and
amplification instrument of what the
manufacturer what's a serial number
these are all identifiers that when you
call upon you validate and you should
check the calibration verification on
these instrumentations of these assets
and material setups this is where you
can define materials we have a
predefined material miss in there
because we are we are like technologies
or your acrobatics and we have status of
controls but again this software does
not require our materials we used it can
be to find your materials competitors
materials into the software as well and
so we need to find a material all you
need to define its name as a material
the sample type that the material
belongs in and concentrations of the
material or the material if no so once
you define all those elements the assay
to instrument the materials what you do
next is take that information and start
creating studies and the first thing
we're going to talk about is validation
verification studies and so when you put
information you first select what I they
are you going to do when are you going
to do a validation or verification what
instruments what serial numbers what
ID numbers are either use for your asset
verification you so what's stored inside
the software actually is some predefined
assets so this is something what you're
doing loud develop tests you can we can
create the assays but if there is a ivd
clear test you can select that and all
this information is pre-populated for
example if you selected a roche HIV
version 2.8 immediately you know into
sovereign knows you're doing a
verification you're doing using cobalt
sample prep and you're using in cobalt
tak man and the input volumes are
already predefined into the solver so
everything is predefined then you're
using IBD acid is much much simpler next
stage is the guidelines set up and so
what you see is a list you know you're
doing a verification or a validation and
if this is out all the experiments that
need to be done and you can select
predefined guidelines as well whereas if
you select certain like if you want to
follow plea account New York State or I
saw one probability point a 92 select on
the side and basically it generates
based on a list of peer-reviewed of
articles what are these guidelines how
many days how many replicates how many
replicas of positive levels and negative
levels and then finally you can name and
review the study so a little bit
guideline suggestion again so this is a
snapshot this again what I showed you
earlier was from the insolence paper
this is our interpretation of what that
paper referred to and what you can see
is the number of days replicates and
positive levels and negative levels
required for each one of these
experiments like an illegal sensitivity
qualitative actors now again we want the
software to be as flexible and so this
guideline even though it's a
recommendation the lab is still changing
for example if they disagree they want
more levels to be done during accuracy
analysis they can change the level
and save the guideline uniquely to their
own laboratory and then this guy that
can be called upon again next time when
another validation of every few studies
performed so once that's defined once
the study is defined we have it we have
to design a couple more elements into
the study before generating a protocol
one thing that has to be defined first
off is preparing your materials I know
you might ask okay we just define the
materials well the prepared material
allows you to select what you want to do
with these materials are usually to
dilute the materials we just want you to
select these these aspects of what
you're going to do you will actually
create dilutions schemes that you need
to perform in order to get the level the
correct levels to meet the guidelines
you can define additional controls and
controls any laboratory samples that you
want to run inside the studies as well
as additional standards you can also set
acceptance criteria now this is
important because you can move past to
generate protocol new set of such as
criteria for each one of your statistics
that you want to perform for example you
have to set several percent Seavey's
acceptable Delta laws from the expected
for a quantitative accuracy study all
these need to be set I mean there's some
experiments or substitutes in there that
don't need acceptance criteria like LOD
where you're establishing an lod but for
most cases everything needs to be set a
substance right here and this is up to
the lab how they want to set these
acceptance criteria once once the study
is completed and all statistically
analyzed the results are compared
against the acceptance criteria network
were originally set so you define
reagents and this is where you actually
defined a lot numbers like expiration
dates of your agents you can then also
arrange your plates so if you have a
96-well plate or a 384-well plate or
something else and you don't like to set
up right now it's just setting it up
horizontally you can actually change it
to however way you want it want it to go
and then you can define the operator
school in this who in your laboratory is
actually performed is not Asia
verification all this information is
then and then use to generate protocol
so before you show you the protocol just
wanted to talk about the plate layout
really quaint just be really quick you
can drag and drop your samples anywhere
along the plates and it will save your
plate layout the reason this is also
very important is when you're creating a
multiplex assing it also uses the same
mechanism so the division of 384-well
plate or a nice as well played and you
want to find that this column is this
target and disk all the dist argot you
would drag these targets into this plate
and if the software will remember that
this is the plate layout of your
multiplex passe so protocol so as I said
after all this information is design you
generate a protocol and you can generate
a PDF protocol or a word document and
this word document that can be used can
be modified to meet your laboratories
needs if you need to add on a cover
sheet additional signatures any type of
templates that you guys typically use
but inside this protocol is a summary
it's a summary of the entire study you
get your whole list of all the plate
layouts and you get your dilation
schemes basically this protocol is meant
to be a self-contained protocol that the
laboratory can then take into know that
the operator can take engine and
laboratory clip through it and this runs
at the end of the protocols of what last
patient actually a signature page for
the lab director the person who wrote
the protocol and approvals so now we're
moving into the third stage of the study
which is where we're running this done
now just to let you know what they want
to talk about the software is that the
solver actually has hierarchical access
so whereas I know I mentioned the
director I mentioned during my talk to
supervisor also mentioned the operator /
technician these are different
access levels for these users and these
allow them to set they have different
responsibilities within the software so
a lab director can only approve the
protocol a supervisor can design the
study an operator can run run and input
data into the software this allows
laboratories to control and protect
their data from any accidental changes
or anything so going into running
studies so it's important that once you
get the data that you put it in right
away you analyze it you put together
organized plans so that you get a clear
picture of how your ass is performing
and so that's what we want to do with
the software we wanted to create a
statistical package inside the software
they can do all these analysis there's
other statistical packages out there I
mean there's there's what the
laboratories I would imagine majority of
laboratories use spreadsheet programs
like Excel and they have templates they
code in the statistics other software's
are out there but it's like EP evaluator
analyze it but what we did with our
software is that it's statistical
analysis but it has that front end with
the guidelines how to guide people and
the flexibility to adapt to the
laboratories needs so when you record
results into your software you first of
all you set your date what date did you
run your results again you can put into
block numbers and reagent expiration
dates if you pre defined it in your
study it's all pre populated into those
offer immediately when uploading data
you can manually enter the data and it's
very similar to a spreadsheet like
format you can just type in your values
either in log or scientific notation the
software will know what type of value
you're trying to put in you could you
can also upload and you can upload using
Excel spreadsheet or a CSV file and the
software would then upload immediately
the data into and populate these cells
once you have all the data populated
there you can manually exclude values if
for some reason you know that this value
there was a pipe any error and even
though there's a value that came out
it's probably not a reliable value you
think meanly nor the value and comment
and ignoring a value will remove it from
the statistical analysis it'd still be
there in the final report though because
the raw data will all be stored inside
the report so before the statistical
analysis is completed immediately the
software does outlier analysis after the
last data point is put in and now my
analysis gives gives the user a view of
what possibly could be an outlier and it
does utilizes a boxplot method to do and
how Larry analysis this here is an
example from a method correlation study
where they were had a reference method
as well as a comparative method and this
is when they're doing an outlier
analysis for each one of the levels that
was used in that reference method and
that comparative method so we use
boxplot like i mentioned amazing outside
three times the interquartile range or
below the three times interquartile
range is fly to the outlier the software
again does not exclude that value
immediately it just Flags it the youth
is up to the users responsibility if
they want to deem it that is truly an
outlier and to eliminate it so once this
is immediately done the statistics are
calculated and this is all Amelia mean
literally it takes you can see a loading
bar as the statistic sadistic are
calculated and within a minute all the
statistics are completed and a report is
generated so I'm just going to go over a
couple statistics I'm not going to go
over all senses things just give their
snap child what's the decision to
perform how it looks and what are the
graphical displays our show for example
here is accuracy what we see here is
this is you get a different spot or
bland-altman plot this is where you're
comparing your observed value this was
run off an hcv panel your observed value
versus the expected value and in the set
of criteria you set what is an
acceptable Delta law and
for example in this case unfortunate i
can't see those uh the fun is very very
small hopefully its larger on your side
but i think it's point 3 or point three
logs so they send a difference at point
three logs and what the labret what the
software does is to calculate all the
law of differences and if it's less than
that point three logs difference it's a
pass if it's greater it's a fail and you
get a plan all event the red is the mean
the solid line is a perfect different
spot where difference of zero and we can
see that we're slightly slightly under
qualifying across the abyss half a but
it's still within specifications next
thing we can look at is linearity and so
this is just a regression analysis plot
it looks at certain subject areas like
what's acceptable slope and a perfect
slope we're meaning expected values is a
slope of 1 and so we look at perfection
how close is it to a slope of 1
interceptor also is looking how close we
acceptable intercept to intercept of 0
another statistic a little bit more
complicated is the limit of detection
analysis or the analytical sensitivity
and this is where we do a probit
regression on the data and when you do a
limited in textual analysis you're
taking in the guideline they recommend
about six levels and ten replicants for
each one of those novels and it does and
here we do a binary analysis where we do
cause it or negative what is the number
of detected levels and one of the
numbers of negative levels and we didn't
do a program regression and identify
what is what is a concentration that has
a ninety-five percent detection limit in
this case the 95 per ship to ninety-five
percent deviation is 90.3 i use per ml
we also can calculate the confidence
confidence interval which is for in this
case 75 to about a hundred and eight
so again reminder if there's any
questions put it into the QA console and
we'll get to that at the end of the end
of the talk once offices in analysis a
report is generated and this is very
similar to the protocol again is a word
document or a PDF document it is just
summary of all your results what you did
what the valuation schemes were done it
also gives you the raw data what you
ignored what when you commented out and
signature pages again where you can
record for have approvals the lab
director approvals or supervisor
approval and you can then take this
report and follow away so this is what
the final stage it is a very very simple
process so again we went through the
four stages really creative software we
design your study we selected what
assays you're going to use we went into
defining your studies where we define
the materials prepared the materials
what acceptance criteria and then we
went into running and running the data
and then finally we analyzed and
generated the report and that's what we
hope with those audience software that
we could streamline this process as you
can see it was just a couple pages a
couple inputs and immediately protocols
reports are generated and yet the
solvers still have the capabilities to
reflects a bold enough you can set your
own the substance traitors you can
change the guidelines and have you
change the guidelines the software will
will change as needed and once even in
their hitting in there that I could
attain show is that there's a lot of
optimization built into the software for
example when you saw the guidelines you
solve there's replicates and levels for
accuracy there's replicates and levels
or linearity replicates of levels for
dynamic range well for most cases you
realize as you're writing experience
well I could use a data from accuracy
for the linearity study I can use a data
from the linear say for the timing
dynamic range study I do not need to run
separate levels replication and for each
one of these studies the solver actually
is aware of that and will actually
combine materials combined the materials
that you define into to give you the
biggest bang for your buck it basically
will allow you to do as much with that
one
run with that material it basically
saves time saves reagents costs and
saves materials so going outside of
validation verification now we're going
to talk very quickly about calibration
verification this is a very very simple
of statistics as one why do we run
calibration verification well this is in
the US as required by Clea is required
for quantitative assays that every six
months the step three levels are tested
high medium and low it is tested as
within the assay still performing fit
calibration in typically done this is
done using other samples that the lab
may have or even like standards and
controls that we could provide or other
competitors could provide what this
offered us is that it doesn't accuracy
analysis it does but actually a
knowledge I everywhere accuracy analysis
sorry about that and accuracy analysis
for the the levels and the cool thing
about this is that your dashboard tells
you whether you are in calibration where
what date you are on and at the end a
month before the six month expiration
date it would actually send me an email
reminding you please do your calibration
verification so the final module that we
are going to talk about his QC
monitoring in daily QC and no I know
that this is something that's typically
done using Excel spreadsheets or is done
more frequently in a clinical chemistry
environment or even and it's basically
monitoring and we're utilizing loving
jennings plots and Westgard rules to
establish these control limits and what
levels are what they fall inside the
control limits or warning lines so again
why do we run daily QC controls the cap
chat which requires us to run these
controls well that's for some special
exceptions for quantitative test and
typically require
there's three run controls a negative
below and a high positive control if
you're running a quality tests you can
run negative controls or positive
controls so this software actually can
track your controls over a time period
and daily kiss you see allows
laboratories to see drifts over time and
we didn't go into details of how we can
slice and dice is data the software
biology is a slice and dice just data
into many many different formats what we
go a little bit further with daily QC is
that we added pure comparison we will go
into a little bit more detail about what
Peter where's and why peer comparison
might be important to your laboratory
peer comparison allows you to actually
see how the performers seriously stacks
up to other laboratories that utilizing
the same controls and the same posse so
we create a loving Jennings plots with
this with the daily QC and we can set
control limits and these are three
standard deviations prostitute and
Tuesday to standard deviation warning
lines when sending this up we set the
control limits you can select it by
lawton of what Lots you want to use what
control laws you want to use and you can
compute these controlling with these
warning light she's 37 aviation to
standard deviation warning lights from
met by manually entering the value which
you manually enter the mean and the
sandy nations of your controls on the
NSA or you can actually ask the software
to compute the control limits from
previous runs and you can select update
how far you want to go back how many
number how many number of control runs
did you run into establish those means
and standard deviations based on this
data when you generate a report you can
slice and dice what I said you just
slice and dice the data in many
different ways you can view it by the
ass a lot number the control lot number
the instrumentation ID the operator and
then you can view these control of its
based on those inputs
if you select my lab that's what you're
doing you're checking your operators
your operators your assay your control
laws but if you select my network or all
laboratories this is where we're going
more into the peer comparison portion of
the software final that you can do in
the software has actually send you
automatic reports so you need to select
a frequency reports if you want to get a
report what your operator entering data
every day every week or every month this
will then be emailed to you in you a PDF
will be emailed to you showing you the
performance of your assay every day so
network and peer comparison now this is
a little this is always a little bit
contentious because this sharing data
the sharing of the data this allows you
to share your QC monitoring it also if
in some cases also allows you to share
protocols in the validation verification
you can collaborate with allow you can
set different levels of sharing you can
choose not to share any data you can
choose to share data with only your
network or you can share choose share
data with all your peers and what I mean
by network so this software also because
about cloud-based is a web-based
software it allows you to kind of do
like a link in LinkedIn like a
laboratory linked in between each other
and this allows you to invite another
laboratory to join your network and you
can set send out emails inviting you
them and make an exception where they
can decline the invitation and once they
joined a network you can then do peer
comparison with these other networks so
just a couple more slides and then we're
done peer comparison just to give you a
quick snapshot of your comparison these
are a couple graphs that are available
in to peer comparison module you can
assess how precise your assay is
performing compare the other labs so in
this case the red dot is where this lab
is performing precision wise where there
I say across all the other labs is right
there in the middle you also get a union
plot which compares the precision as
well as the accuracy and basically if
you're closer to the center where you're
pretty where you're pretty much accurate
compared to all the other labs and
pretty and precise compared to all the
other labs are in the green area of the
lab and yellow orange red a
distinguished further how far you away
from accuracy and precision to resonator
labs
you